there's nothing quite like a good fight
scene who doesn't love seeing cinemas
greatest martial artists do get out on
the big screen but while they might look
awesome throwing those high kicks some
of the most iconic martial arts actors
don't even have a black belt it's
probably important to get a handle on
how the belt system works
it's also worth knowing that the term
martial arts is plural for a reason
there are hundreds of different schools
of fighting across the globe and as much
as movies like to simplify things down
to either karate or kung-fu those are
only two of the most popular styles
they're certainly not the only ones
practiced by martial arts actors in fact
most of these disciplines don't follow a
belt system at all and many of the most
revered martial arts actors have no belt
simply because none were offered by
their discipline many martial arts
actors also come from a dance background
instead of a fighting one this tracks
because the main attribute for a movie
star is performance not victory fight
scenes in any movie especially martial
arts movies are about cooperation and
telling a story rather than defeating an
opponent the best comparison is
professional wrestling where many
wrestlers show off their skills by
fighting invisible men to demonstrate
how to take bumps and tell stories at
the same time there's also a trend in
martial arts now known as black belt
factories or McDo [ __ ] schools that
teach watered-down fast-paced martial
arts lessons with a goal of pumping out
as many black belts as possible this is
done just so people can have the
prestige of having a black belt without
putting in the work many martial arts
websites now offer warnings about black
belt factories and how to spot them in
other words in today's age black belts
can be highly overrated and just because
an actor doesn't have one that doesn't
mean they don't know what they're doing
Bruce Lee is the name most associated
with martial arts movies and too many
people martial arts in general the old
single-handedly started the martial arts
revolution in the West his movies are
bedrocks of the martial arts movie genre
and he never had a black belt in any
discipline Lee's primary martial arts
background was in Wing Chun which he
studied directly under the famous hit
man he excelled at this art but it just
so happened that Wing Chun offered no
belts to its students when we moved to
America he's studied acting at the
University of Washington he soon began
teaching his own variation of Wing Chun
which eventually morphed into jeet kune
do-- he described this as a hybrid style
rather than an
organised institution and it's this
philosophy that shines throughout all of
these movies as an actor as a martial
artist as a human being all these I have
learned from Marshall David Carradine
was best known for starring as the
titular villain in Kill Bill and in the
TV show kung fu is Caine a Shaolin monk
wandering the American Old West kung-fu
was the first exposure many Americans
had to come foo or to any other kind of
martial arts and in many ways Carradine
was the face of American martial arts
but not only did Carradine have no black
belt ER in the height of the show's
popularity he also lacked any kind of
formal martial arts training whatsoever
Carradine originally relied on his
experience and dance gymnastics and
fencing through the early stages of the
show's run he later developed a deeper
interest in kung foo and while he never
became a master he nonetheless saw
himself as something of an ambassador
for the style Carradine later learned
enough martial arts to produce his own
instructional videos on tight cheap but
aspera skill as a fighter as Chuck
Norris who faced him in lone wolf
McQuade once quipped David Carradine is
about as good a martial artist as I am
an actor gina carano is the most
recognizable name in women's MMA for
years and she since gone on to enjoy a
solid career in acting in addition to a
series of direct-to-video martial arts
movies for the diehards she has also
appeared in Fast & Furious 6 Deadpool
and the mandalorian despite all these
accomplishments however she doesn't have
a black belt at least not yet
Carano got her start in Muay Thai which
doesn't follow traditional belt rankings
she compiled a 12-1 in one record before
getting involved in MMA where she found
even more success Khurana was often
labeled the face of women's MMA where
she compiled the seven and one MMA
record her final match was a loss
against Chris cyborg and the first ever
women's match to headline a major MMA
event not long after her Carano went
into acting but she never left martial
arts behind in 2014 she started
practicing Brazilian jiu-jitsu working
her way up from a white belt gently is
one of the most recognizable martial
arts stars out there American fans will
know impre movies such as hero fearless
unleashed and more commercial fares such
as The Expendables and lead the weapon
for all of this is backed
with genuine skill too manly is a
champion in at least one field of
martial arts that said he's never
acquired a black belt this is because ly
studies wushu our martial art with no
belt ranking system from a young age he
was a martial arts prodigy competing
against adults before he was even a
teenager and winning the number of
medals in the process at one point his
wushu team made a visit to the White
House and met Richard Nixon the
president humorously offered the young
Lee a role as a bodyguard Lee responded
I don't want to protect any individual
when I grow up I want to defend my 1
billion Chinese countrymen Lee retired
at age 19 to pursue a career in film
Michelle Yeoh is one of the most famous
martial arts actresses of her era most
known to Western audiences for her turn
is Wei Lin and Tomorrow Never Dies and
you shoot Leon and Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon
yo also has a long history of starring
in major Hong Kong action flicks she
performs many of her own stunts too
despite having no formal martial arts
training and no belt of any kind
yo is a natural athlete growing up but
her true passion was ballet she attended
the Royal Academy of Dance in London
before her mother entered her in a
beauty pageant which she won that
victory landed her and offered a star in
a commercial with Jackie Chan and this
snowballed into her acting career in
Hong Kong and eventually Hollywood as
for martial arts
yo once said I don't profess to be I
can't profess to be a martial artist
because I've never been formally trained
I've never gone through the belt system
because I never had the time in that way
Ching Pepe has often considered the
first female martial arts star she had a
long and successful career and was at
one time one of the biggest stars of the
Hong Kong martial arts genre her role in
come drink with me is considered one of
the iconic appearances within the kung
fu movie genre but Western audiences
might recognize her from return as Jade
Fox and Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
of course Chang accomplished all of this
without a black belt of her own Chang
started her career as a dancer she came
to the attention of wushu film director
Qing foo who was convinced that her
skills and dance could translate to
combat she had her doubts but accepted
the challenge head-on as she later said
I wanted to beat all the boys if the
boys could do it I could too Chang's
willingness to get physical take a punch
and do her own stunts got her far in the
industry and cemented her legacy is one
of the all-time
it's greats Eve Torres made her name in
the WWE where she won the 2007 Diva
Search and went on to hold the WWE Divas
Championship three times after retiring
from wrestling in 2013 she took on
acting work playing chancara in the
Scorpion King 4 and facing off against
Jackie Chan and skiptrace she also
appeared in an episode of Supergirl as
the villainous maximum because Torres
comes from a dance background however
she has no black belt to speak up
she was co-captain of the fly girls
USC's hip-hop dance crew and also danced
for the NBA Summer League she won the a
/ mentioned 2007 WWE Diva Search and
worked full time as a wrestler for six
years during her time as a wrestler
Torres started practicing Brazilian
jiu-jitsu in 2014 she married henna
gracie of the famous gracie BJJ family
who she met while training at the gracie
academy she was awarded the purple belt
in 2016 after nearly nine years of study
and now teaches the gracie women
empowerment self-defense program
Robin Shu was one of the most notable
martial arts actors of the 90s best
known for playing Liu Kang in both
Mortal Kombat's and Mortal Kombat
annihilation he also starred in Beverly
Hills ninja opposite Chris Farley on top
of that Shu appeared in all three of
Paul WS Anderson s death race movies
choose studied karate and college but
disliked it so he left the martial arts
world behind to become a civil engineer
but while on vacation in Hong Kong he
was recruited to be in a martial arts
movie because of his noticeable large
shoe size he performed his stunts so
well that it quickly snowballed into a
movie career Chiu later studied wushu a
martial art with no belt ranking and has
since used that as a basis for all of
his fighting scenes even before the
Keano sauce brought on by John wick
Keanu Reeves has enjoyed a long and
illustrious career as an action movie
star you wanted me back
his turns in speed and Point Break first
demonstrated his big-screen combat
skills before the matrix put him on the
martial-arts map and his recent movies
has shown off even more of the actors
fighting skills but despite battling
Agent Smith and facing down the Russian
mob Reeves has never actually earned a
black belt Reeves has a bit of a sporty
background as he was a successful hockey
goalie during his school years but for
the titular role of John wick he had to
learn both judo and Brazilian jiu-jitsu
since many of the action sequences in
the movies feature moves that are very
common at BJJ since he started from the
bottom he earned a white belt and has
been steadily working his way up in 2017
he was awarded an honorary black belt
but he has yet to earn the real thing
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu is one of the most
popular forms of martial arts for actors
one such practitioner was the late Paul
Walker who loved BJJ but never got his
black belt at least while he was alive
Walker was an enthusiastic student of
BJJ
he even made sure his movies included
action scenes that highlighted his
skills instead of simple punches and
kicks and techniques from his training
sessions were included throughout the
Fast and Furious franchise Walker
trained for almost 10 years under
Ricardo Miller of Paragon Brazilian
jiu-jitsu in Los Angeles and wanted more
than anything to be a black belt he knew
he'd have to earn it however and once
said I will get my black belt even if I
need to get it in my coffin
tragically Walker fell shy of his goal
before he died in a car accident - 2013
Miller posthumously awarded Walker of
black belt at his memorial service check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you